un choc comme ça parce que la mort de
compatriotes chinois
ça nous fait vraiment là peu parce que
on pensait que on n'a pas discuté pas
combien s'en est pourtant la magie ne
seront pas bouillie camp messin
l'émotion est encore très vive au
lendemain du meurtre de monsieur linh en
plein centre ville de fort-de-france
l' enquête criminelle qui débute va
devoir faire la lumière sur les
circonstances et le mobile de ce meurtre
si la piste xénophobe n'est pas
privilégiée la communauté chinoise tient
quand même à monter au créneau pour
l'instant il est trop tôt pour dire si
on est ciblé tout ce qu'on sait c'est
que les c'est la première fois que comme
maçon est abattu en plein jour en plein
fort-de-france juste devant la mairie
dans son magasin pendant qu'il ouvrait
son magasin un comité de soutien s'est
monté pour aider la veuve du gérant
assassiner les associations foyalaise de
commerçants dénoncent aujourd'hui la
montée d'un sentiment d'insécurité
un phénomène qui pourrait être enrayée
par une meilleure animation du centre
ville le fait qu'ils aient plus de monde
au centre ville fera que bell et les
voyous n'ont plus leur place et
et ne pourront plus faire leurs méfaits
en pleine activité un système de
vidéosurveillance alors oui un système
qui alors ça devrait rassurer mais après
faut-il encore qu'il fonctionne
entièrement est pleinement aussi vivre
les verbalisations que les pour les
agressions qui se font aujourd'hui
pourtant depuis la mise en place de
cette vidéo surveillance il ya une
dizaine d'années les faits de
délinquance aurait largement diminué
dans le centre ville la municipalité
rappelle que la sécurité est une
compétence régalienne de l'état mais que
le partenariat engagé avec celui ci
porte ses fruits
même s'il reste beaucoup à faire la
ville contribue justement à sécuriser
l'espace public par l'ajout de caméras
supplémentaires caméras de vidéo
protection supplémentaire par du
personnel supplémentaire mais également
par la présence justement des
patrouilles mixtes police municipale
police nationale donc il y a peut être
un sentiment d'insécurité mais nous
faisons tout justement pour lutter
contre ce sentiment de sécurité
les proches de la victime et des
associations appellent à manifester dans
la rue la semaine prochaine pour
demander plus de sécurité et rendre
hommage ou commerçants assassiné